far more than we're inclined to accept
and sometimes even realize we are
creatures of mood that is our sense of
our value as human beings is prone to
extraordinary fluctuation at times we
know how to tolerate ourselves the
future seems benevolent we can bear who
we are in the eyes of others and we can
forgive ourselves for the desperate
errors of the past and then at other
points the mood dips and we lament most
of what we've ever done we see ourselves
as natural targets for contempt we feel
undeserving guilty weak and headed for
retribution and disaster but it can be
very hard to grasp what causes our moods
to shift a day that started with energy
and hope can by lunchtime end up mired
in self-hatred and tearfulness a sure
sense that we finally turned the corner
and are on the way to better things can
be replaced at speed by an alternative
certainty that we are a cosmic error we
cannot it appears ever prevent our moods
from being subject to change but what is
open to us all is to learn how to manage
the change more effectively so that our
downturns can be ever so slightly more
gentle our sadness more containable and
our inconstancy less shameful in our
eyes here is some of what we might learn
to bear in mind around our capricious
moods firstly realize our vulnerability
we should acknowledge how vulnerable our
moods are to being perturbed by
so-called small things we belong to a
species of extreme but also fateful
sensitivity we shouldn't expect to be
able to appreciate a Mozart Aria or a
Rembrandt self-portrait on the one hand
and then on the other stay unbothered by
the down turn corners of the mouth of a
lover or the slightly distant gaze of a
would-be client we shouldn't berate
ourselves for how thin our skin is we
should adjust ourselves to the full
consequences of our
extraordinary openness to experience
unless we take vigorous measures to edit
our social lives we can to easily find
ourselves in the company of people who
though they may call themselves our
friends are in terms of what they do to
our moods no such thing beneath a veneer
of kindness these people are the bearers
of latent hostility a deadly
competitiveness self-absorbed hysteria
or priggish moralism to start to be a
friend to ourselves means learning to
take a scalpel to our address list in
order to edit out all the dispiriting
imposters the one great solace for a low
mood is the right sort of company people
who know how to reassure us that we
still belong that sadness is to be
expected and that our errors never put
us beyond compassion these consoling
souls will have suffered they will have
hated themselves and they will have
learned how to laugh at the absurdity of
being human most importantly when we
show them our low mood they will know
how gracefully to take that most
essential next step of friendship accept
our flaws and display one or two of
their own maddeningly some of why our
moods shift is that we inhabit a body
but because it's so humiliating to have
to accept that our ideas about ourselves
and our lives might be dependent on
bodily factors like how long we slept
how much water we've drunk what viruses
we might be fighting in the background
the temptation can be to insist that our
ideas must solely be the offspring of
reason but it would be wiser to
interpret that most of what passes
through our minds is in some way
dependent on particular things going on
in our bodies at points it isn't that
it's all over and that were the worst
person on earth it's just that we may
need to lie down for an hour or agent
Lee have a glass of orange juice moods
are proud imperious things they show up
and insist that they're telling us total
certainties about our identities and our
prospects
perhaps that our love lives will never
work out or that a professional
situation is beyond repair but we always
have an option of calling their bluff of
realizing that they are only a passing
state of mind arrogantly pretending to
be the whole of us and that we could
with courage politely ignore them and
change the subject we might recognize
but not give way to the mood and put a
bit of distance between it and our
conscious selves we might at times even
do precisely what a mood commands us not
to do like see someone rather than cede
to shame or show our face rather than
give way to paranoia or go out for a
walk
rather than fold our limbs into a fetal
position while we're being rocked by a
dark mood we should strive to keep a
little light on the light of sanity and
self kindness that can tell us even
though a hurricane is insisting
otherwise that we are not appalling that
we have done nothing unforgivable and
that we have a right to be we can strive
to keep ourselves plugged in to a small
pilot light of kindness until a larger
Sun is ready to rise once more not only
do difficult moods insist that they are
correct they also seek to convince us
that they are permanent but our sense of
self is naturally viscous we are
condemned to rise and then fall to flow
and then AB we are as a reality and as a
metaphor largely made of water so we
shouldn't allow a misplaced ideal of
permanence to add to our sorrows though
we may be unable to shift a mood we can
at least realize that it is only ever
such a thing and that in the inestimable
words of the prophets with the help of a
few hours or days it too shall pass our
emotional barometer is a tool that can
help us to more clearly explain our
moods click the link on screen now to
find out more
you